foreign
[Music]
we call on all the international
organizations and the UN agencies to
provide safety and food and to protect
civilians we also ask for the return of
Health Services because the situation
here in Janina is a catastrophe all
International organizations and civil
societies should direct their assistance
to Janina
[Music]
come down
not everybody came we left the old
people they're still there we can't go
back to get them we don't know what to
do we don't have anything to go and
fight these people maybe the government
of Chad can help us rescue the elderly
[Music]
foreign
there is an African proverb that says if
your neighbor's Hut is on fire you must
prepare yourself so yours doesn't catch
fire too
[Music]